SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WILL COME
TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON,
EVERYONE. WE HAVE JUST ONE BILL
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. AND THE
AUTHOR, WHICH IS SENATOR
SKINNER, IS UNAVAILABLE. SO I AM
GOING TO PRESENT THE BILL ON HER
BEHALF WHEN WE GET THERE. WE
DON'T QUITE HAVE A QUORUM. SO I
THINK WE CAN START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO JUST DO A CALL OUT REALLY
QUICK TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
ON SENATE BPD. THIS IS GOING TO
BE QUICK. SO PLEASE HUSTLE DOWN
HERE IF YOU CAN. AND THEN I
THINK WE WILL JUST GO TO
PRESENTING THIS. IF MY VICE
CHAIR WOULDN'T MIND HELPING ME
OUT, MADAM CHAIR, PLEASE
PROCEED. WE ARE LOOKING AT SB
233. THE ONLY ITEM ON THE AGENDA
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I'M GOING TO
MAKE THIS AS QUICK AS WE CAN.
AND I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE WITH ME. SB 233
TEMPORARILY ALLOWS ARIZONA
DOCTORS TO PROVIDE ABORTION CARE
TO ARIZONA PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT SUNSETS IN
NOVEMBER OF 2024. ON 30TH ON
JUNE 6TH, 2024, ARIZONA WILL
FACE A TOTAL ABORTION BAN. IT'S
A NEW LAW FOR THEM. TRIGGERS 2
TO 5 YEAR STATE PRISON SENTENCE
FOR DOCTORS WHO PROVIDE CARE.
LACK OF ACCESS TO SAFE,
EFFECTIVE DOCTOR PROVIDED
ABORTION MEANS EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS CONDITIONS FOR
PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS WHO SEEK TO
DO THIS ON THEIR OWN. STUDIES
SAY AN ABORTION BAN WITHIN THE
US WOULD LEAD TO A 21% INCREASE
IN PREGNANCY RELATED DEATHS, A
33% INCREASE IN PREGNANCY
RELATED DEATHS AMONG BLACK
WOMEN, AND ALSO 1 IN 5 ABORTION
PATIENTS NATIONWIDE TRAVELED OUT
OF STATE TO OBTAIN ABORTION CARE
IN THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF 2023
TO PRACTICE, ARIZONA DOCTOR
MUST, AMONG OTHER THINGS, HOLD
AND VERIFY THAT THEY HAVE A
MEDICAL LICENSE IN GOOD STANDING
FROM ARIZONA AND MUST HAVE
PERFORMED AT LEAST ONE ABORTION
UNDER THEIR ARIZONA LICENSE
WITHIN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT POST
INFORMATION ON ITS WEBSITE
REGARDING THESE PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS FROM IDENTITY
PROTECTION PURPOSES. ARIZONA HAS
REPEALED THEIR 1864 LAW, BUT THE
REPEAL DOESN'T BECOME EFFECTIVE
UNTIL LATE OCTOBER OR EARLY
NOVEMBER AT THE EARLIEST, WHICH
LEAVES A WINDOW OF CARE THAT
THIS BILL WOULD THEN COVER,
PROVIDING ARIZONA DOCTORS THE
ABILITY TO DETERMINE HOW BEST TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THEIR
PATIENTS. I WILL ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR, IS THERE ANY
SPONSORS OR LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. I THINK TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY IS
PLANNED PARENTHOOD. YEP. COME ON
UP. HI SYMPHONY. OKAY. AND WE'LL
ALLOW EACH, SPEAKER TO
WITNESSES. TWO MINUTES. Þ GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS SYMPHONY BARBIE WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING THE
SEVEN PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES IN THE STATE WHO
PROVIDE CARE TO OVER 100 HEALTH
CENTERS. AND WE ARE PROUD
SUPPORTERS OF SENATE BILL 233.
THE OVERTURNING OF ROE V WADE
HAS CAUSED A WAVE OF CONFUSION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, MAKING IT
UNCLEAR WHETHER THERE IS ACCESS
TO ABORTION OR NOT IN CERTAIN
STATES. A NEAR-TOTAL BAN
HAPPENING IN OUR NEIGHBORING
STATE OF ARIZONA WILL ONLY ADD
TO THAT CONFUSION. ON APRIL 9TH,
THE ARIZONA SUPREME COURT ISSUED
A DECISION THAT WOULD ALLOW A
CIVIL WAR ERA BAN ON ABORTION TO
GO INTO EFFECT AS SOON AS NEXT
MONTH. LAST WEEK, THE ARIZONA
ATTORNEY GENERAL ANNOUNCED
EFFORTS TO DELAY ENFORCEMENT,
AND ARIZONA'S GOVERNOR SIGNED A
BILL INTO LAW TO REPEAL THE BAN.
AS A RESULT, IT IS UNCLEAR WHEN
THE 1864 BAN COULD GO INTO
EFFECT AND FOR HOW LONG. SINCE
DOBBS, ABORTION BANS HAVE BEEN
ENACTED RESTRICTING ABORTION IN
21 STATES, INCLUDING ARIZONA.
THESE BANS ARE CRUEL AND
ENDANGER THE HEALTH OF PREGNANT
PEOPLE AND EXACERBATE EXISTING
BARRIERS TO CARE. SB 233
REAFFIRMS CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT AS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE AND MAKES SURE OUR
NEIGHBORS KNOW THAT ABORTION IS
STILL LEGAL AND ACCESSIBLE IN
CALIFORNIA, REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY MAY TRAVEL FROM. WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE SO THAT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HAS THE CAPACITY TO
TREAT ALL PATIENTS WHO NEED
CARE. HOWEVER, AS THE NATIONAL
LANDSCAPE CHANGES, WE ALSO
APPRECIATE ANY ADDITIONAL TOOLS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO BE IN A STATE
THAT IS COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
ACCESS TO ABORTION, AND WE STAND
READY TO SERVE ALL PATIENTS WANT
TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER, THE
MAJORITY LEADER, AND THE CHAIR
FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL. AND
AS MEMBERS OF THE FUTURE OF
ABORTION COUNCIL PAC
RESPECTFULLY URGES YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THIS TIME, THERE'S ANY OF THE
WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO,
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION. GOOD AFTERNOON.
VRINDA WOODBURY, ON BEHALF OF
GOVERNOR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS AS A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING THERE'S
NO OTHER AT THIS TIME, WE'LL ASK
FOR LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE. WE'RE THEN GOING TO
SEE IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
COME UP AND JUST SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE THE BILL, SEEING NONE
BRING IT BACK TO, OH, I'M SORRY.
MIKE MURRAY, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THIS TIME, WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO ALL
RIGHT. YES, PLEASE. I NEED SOME
CLARIFICATION ON. SURE. SO YOU
STATED SOME OF THE DATES, THE,
THE SUPREME COURT, UPHELD THE
1864 LAW, WHICH, FRANKLY, I
DON'T THINK THEY REALLY HAD A
CHOICE ON THAT. THE LEGISLATURE
HAD TO ACT OTHERWISE, WHICH THEY
HAVE. AND IT'S NOT, I AGREE,
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHEN THAT LAW
WILL TAKE EFFECT, BECAUSE IT IS
90 DAYS AFTER THEY CONCLUDE
THEIR SESSION. RIGHT. AND YOU
DON'T KNOW WHEN THAT'LL BE. BUT
IT IT'S SOMEWHERE AROUND THE END
OF JULY. SO THAT MEANS THAT THE
LAW WILL TAKE EFFECT, PROBABLY
THE END OF OCTOBER OR SO,
COINCIDENT WITH THAT, A COURT
HAS STAYED THE DECISION,
ENABLING THE ORIGINAL STATUTE
UNTIL SEPTEMBER 26, THAT'S ABOUT
A FOUR WEEK WINDOW, RIGHT? YEAH.
POTENTIALLY EIGHT IF THEY END A
LITTLE LATER THAN USUAL AND GO
INTO NOVEMBER. SO, YEAH, YOU'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT PROVIDING A
VERY SHORT WINDOW. I MEAN, AT
THE ROOT OF YOUR QUESTION IS
ARIZONA HAS TRIED TO SOLVE THIS
THEMSELVES, AND THEY'RE REALLY
CLOSE TO HAVING A SOLUTION THAT
COVERS ALL OF THEIR BASES. BUT
THERE'S A 4 TO 8 WEEK WINDOW
THAT IS NOT COVERED, BUT THEY'VE
ELIMINATED IT BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN AWAY FROM ANY
COUNTY ATTORNEYS ANY ABILITY TO
PROSECUTE UNDER THE LAW, AND HAS
MADE IT THE EXCLUSIVE
JURISDICTION OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, WHO IN TURN HAS SAID
THAT THEY WILL NOT ENFORCE IT.
SO THAT'S TRUE, BUT IT'S STILL A
LAW ON THE BOOKS WHERE, YEAH,
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE ENFORCED
ANYWAY. AND THEN ADDITIONALLY,
BECAUSE OF ACTS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE, IF I UNDERSTAND THE
ACTS CORRECTLY, THE SERVICES
WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA, TO, PATIENTS FROM
ARIZONA, JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
STATE. DO YOU WANT ME TO ANSWER
A COUPLE OF THOSE QUESTIONS? SO
FIRST OF ALL, YES, CALIFORNIA IS
A STATE THAT PEOPLE TRAVEL TO,
NOT JUST ARIZONA WHEN THEY NEED
SOME HELP. THE UNIQUENESS OF
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS ACTUALLY
HOW PRECISE IT IS, BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T RELY ON CALIFORNIA
DOCTORS TO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
CASELOAD. IT ALLOWS A PERSON
FROM ARIZONA TO BRING THEIR OWN
DOCTOR WITH THEM. THAT WOULD NOT
BE THE CASE ABSENT THIS BILL. SO
IF WE IF WE DIDN'T DO THIS AT
ALL, COULD PEOPLE FROM ARIZONA
STILL COME HERE IN THAT EIGHT
WEEK WINDOW? YES. COULD THEIR
DOCTOR. NO SO THAT'S THE NUANCE
DIFFERENCE. THE OTHER PIECE
ABOUT YOU SAYING THEY'VE SOLVED
IT THEMSELVES. I KNOW YOU KNOW,
THIS, BUT YES, IT IS A LAW ON
THE BOOKS THAT ALL THE ENTITIES
IN PLACE ARE SAYING THEY WON'T
ENFORCE. BUT IT IS STILL A LAW
ON THE BOOKS. AND AS YOU KNOW,
PROFESSIONALS, PARTICULARLY
DOCTORS, ARE UNDER A PARTICULAR
OATH AND SOME OF THEM MAY FIND
IT HARD TO GO AGAINST THAT OATH
DURING THAT EIGHT WEEK PERIOD.
THIS JUST GIVES THEM ANOTHER
OPTION IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY
WOULDN'T BE VIOLATING ANY LAW,
EVEN IF THEY KNEW TO DO SO. IN
ARIZONA MEANT THEY WOULDN'T
LIKELY SEE PROSECUTION THÀNH
THIS WOULD BE A WAY FOR THEM TO
DO IT WITHOUT JUST RELYING ON
THE WORD OF SOMEBODY SAYING THAT
THEY WOULDN'T USE THE LAW
CURRENTLY IN PLACE. SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S THE NUANCE
DIFFERENCE. SO IN TERMS OF
VIOLATING THE LAW, UNLESS
THEY'RE LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA,
THEY'LL BE VIOLATING CALIFORNIA
LAW. SO, THE, MEDICAL BOARD, THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD, THOSE
BOARDS WILL HAVE TO MAKE
ALLOWANCES FOR THESE
PRACTITIONERS TO PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA LEGALLY, UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. SO TWO QUESTIONS
ON THAT. HOW LONG IS THAT GOING
TO TAKE TO WORK OUT THOSE THE
DETAILS OF THOSE REGULATIONS,
QUESTIONS THAT GO BEHIND THAT,
RELATIVE TO LIABILITY, K¾T,
INSURABILITY, ETC. VÀ, AND, THE
OTHER BROADER QUESTION IS IF
WE'RE WILLING TO DO IT HERE, WHY
DON'T WE DO IT WITH A LOT OF
OTHER, MANY OTHER PRACTICES?
ALSO TO ALLOW IF, IF OUT OF
STATE DOCTORS, ACCOUNTANTS,
LAWYERS, ETC. ARE COMPETENT TO
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA, WHY
DON'T WE OPEN IT UP? WELL, WE
HAVE THAT'S WHAT THIS COMMITTEE
ROUTINELY LOOKS AT. AND THERE
ARE MANY EXAMPLES OVER THE YEARS
OF TIMES THAT BNP HAS DONE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, A
STREAMLINED PROCESS TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO COME TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE WE HAD A
SHORTAGE OF NURSES AS AN
EXAMPLE, TEACHERS IS AN EXAMPLE.
AND AS YOU KNOW, JUST EVEN IN
THE LAST YEAR THAT WE'VE BEEN
HERE REVIEWING BILLS IN BNP,
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
SUGGESTIONS OF GROUPS THAT WE
MIGHT NEED TO STREAMLINE THEIR
ABILITY TO COME INTO CALIFORNIA.
AND I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT WHEN
THE ASSEMBLY BILLS LEAVE THEIR
HOUSE OF ORIGIN AND COME OVER
HERE, WE WILL AGAIN BE LOOKING
AT SOME SUGGESTIONS OF GROUPS
THAT MAYBE WE WOULD STREAMLINE
WAYS IN WHAT I THINK IS UNIQUE
ABOUT THIS BILL AND THE REASON
WHY IT HAD THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AS EARLY AS THE KICK OFF THAT
SOME OF US WERE WERE AT WITH THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS, IS BECAUSE IT IS
A DEFINED PERIOD OF TIME FOR A
DEFINED PURPOSE, AND IT DOESN'T
ADD TO THE CASELOAD OF DOCTORS
HERE, NOR DOES IT TAKE AWAY FROM
THE PATIENTS HERE. RATHER, WHAT
IT DOES IS ALLOW DOCTORS FROM
ARIZONA TO COME WITH THEIR
PATIENT AND GIVE THEM SOME
PRIVILEGES IN A FACILITY THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THIS ONE PROCEDURE DURING
THIS VERY SHORT WINDOW OF TIME,
HAVE THE MEDICAL BOARD OR THE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICAL BOARD, GIVEN
ANY INDICATION THÀNH OF HOW LONG
IT WILL TAKE THEM TO COME UP
WITH THE BACKGROUND ALLOWANCES
THAT THEY HAVE TO FOR
APPROPRIATE LICENSURE? WELL,
ACTUALLY DOING THIS ALLOWS THE
ARIZONA LICENSE TO THEN BE VALID
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR THAT VERY
SHORT WINDOW PERIOD OF TIME. AND
I THINK YOU HEARD PROBABLY IN
SOME OF MY COMMENTS THAT THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
FACTORS ON THIS BILL. FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY HAVE TO HAVE
PERFORMED THAT PARTICULAR
PROCEDURE IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
IN ARIZONA. SO IT DOESN'T OPEN A
FLOODGATE TO ANY KIND OF DOCTOR
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA FOR ANY
PARTICULAR REASON. IT HAD TO BE
FOR THAT PARTICULAR PURPOSE. SO
THE LEGISLATION PROVIDES A
BLANKET AUTHORIZATION. IT
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY THAT IS
SURGICAL IN NATURE FOR THIS ONE
PARTICULAR KIND OF HEALTH CARE
FOR WOMEN. FOR A VERY SMALL
PERIOD OF TIME, TO ASSIST OUR
NEIGHBORS IN ARIZONA WITH A
CONTINUUM OF CARE, WITHOUT ANY
REVIEW BY THE REGULATORY
AUTHORITY. I SUPPOSE WE'RE
RELYING ON ARIZONA'S REGULATORY
REGULATIONS REGULATING AUTHORITY
FOR DOCTORS FOR THAT WINDOW.
YES. OKAY. YEP THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER MEMBERS? SENATOR ARCHULETA
, I HOPE THAT IT WOULD PROVIDE
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT, GOD
FORBID, SOMETHING GOES WRONG
THAT THE DOCTOR RIGHT THERE,
RIGHT THERE CAN GO AHEAD AND, GO
ON TO DO SOMETHING ELSE TO SAVE
THE PATIENT, TAKE CARE OF IT
RIGHT THEN AND THERE. AND YOU'RE
NOT PLAYING. SOMEBODY TAPPED YOU
ON THE SHOULDER AND THIS, THAT
AND THE OTHER THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO SERVE AND REPRESENT
IT AND TAKE CARE OF THAT
PATIENT. AND WHATEVER IS
HAPPENING AND WHATEVER PROCEDURE
IS TAKING PLACE. SURE. AT THAT
MOMENT IN TIME, OF COURSE,
ANYTHING THAT WOULD HAPPEN AS A
RESULT OF THAT PARTICULAR
PROCEDURE HERE WOULD BE UNDER
THE CARE OF THAT DOCTOR. AND I'M
SURE WOULD NOT BE NEW TO ANY OF
THOSE PHYSICIANS. AND AGAIN, THE
CARE OF THE PATIENT IS ULTIMATE.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, I'M JUST
HOPING THAT IT'S NOT
MISINTERPRETED THAT, YOU KNOW,
SOMEBODY TAPPED YOU ON THE
SHOULDER, AS I SAY, AND YOU HAVE
TO WALK AWAY AND SOMEONE ELSE
COMES IN BECAUSE THERE'S A
KIDNEY FAILURE TAKING PLACE OR
SOME OTHER PROBLEM THAT, THAT
THAT PHYSICIAN JUST, YOU KNOW,
NEEDS TO STAY ON, ON THE SPOT
AND TAKE CARE OF IT. I WOULD I
WOULD POTENTIALLY ARGUE THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY THIS IS
ACTUALLY A BETTER SHOT FOR THEM
TO NOT BE INTERRUPTED BECAUSE
THEY WOULD HAVE LEFT THEIR HOME
STATE OF PRACTICE TO COME HERE
FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF ONE
PATIENT, FOR ONE PROCEDURE. AND
I ASSUME WHEN THEY'RE DONE WITH
THAT PROCEDURE, THEY'RE GOING TO
HEAD ON HOME OR ELSE HAVE A VERY
LENGTHY EIGHT WEEK CAREER IN
CALIFORNIA. YEAH YEAH. AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BE LICENSED IN
CALIFORNIA, JUST ARIZONA. WELL,
THEY BECOME LICENSED FOR THIS
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME IN
CALIFORNIA BY VIRTUE OF THEIR
GOOD STANDING IN ARIZONA. OKAY.
THANK YOU. Þ DIÆN. OKAY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND, IT'S A SHAME THAT WE'RE
HERE TODAY, YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
LAW AND YOU THINK ABOUT 1864. I
MEAN, WE STILL HAD SLAVES IN
THIS COUNTRY. WE WERE GOING WAY,
WAY BACK, ON SO MANY RIGHTS THAT
WE ARE CONTINUING TO HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR IN THE 21ST CENTURY IS
JUST SHAMEFUL. BUT ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD ABOUT THE BILL
AND IT CAME UP WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED LEARNING ABOUT THIS
BILL, IS HOW WILL WE ENSURE THAT
WOMEN OF COLOR, PARTICULARLY
BLACK AND BROWN, POOR WOMEN IN
THE STATE OF ARIZONA, WILL KNOW
THAT THIS IS EVEN POSSIBLE AND
AVAILABLE TO THEM, WE KNOW HOW
ACCESS TO CARE IS DIFFICULT,
EVEN IN PARTS OF OUR OWN STATE.
SOUTH CENTRAL BEING ONE OF
THOSE. HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY GET
ACCESS TO CARE, AND HOW DO THE
PHYSICIANS, YOU KNOW, SHARE THIS
INFORMATION THÀNH WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE, I'D
LIKE TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT, YOU WANT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION? THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. YEAH. THANK YOU, SENATOR,
FOR THAT QUESTION. PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HAS BEEN VERY FIRM IN
IN OUR COMMITMENT TO TREATING
PATIENTS FROM ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY, WHETHER THEY COME FROM
ARIZONA OR FROM WISCONSIN,
ANYWHERE, AND IN THE EFFORTS
THAT WE TOOK, THE LEGISLATURE
TOOK IN 2022, AND JUST SINCE THE
FALL OF ROE, WE'VE MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT WE ARE HERE AND THAT
CALIFORNIA IS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE. THAT ALSO
HAPPENED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
DECLARATION OF CALIFORNIA BEING
A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE.
THAT WAS THAT WAS SPREAD FAR AND
WIDE. AND SO AT LEAST FROM THE
PURVIEW OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA, WE'VE
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT WE ARE
HERE AND READY TO SERVE AND THAT
THIS STATE, IS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE AND THAT YOU WILL
BE PROTECTED LEGALLY HERE IN
THIS STATE IF YOU NEED THAT
CARE. SO THAT'S THAT'S MY ANSWER
FOR YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. NO, I APPRECIATE IT.
AND I HOPE THAT IN ARIZONA WE
HAVE TO HAVE IN SOME WAYS WE
USED TO CALL THEM THE
UNDERGROUND NETWORKS. RIGHT. SO
THAT THOSE WOMEN IN THAT STATE
KNOW THAT THEIR PHYSICIAN OR
SOME PHYSICIAN WILL BE ABLE TO
HELP THEM. WHEN YOU'RE POOR, YOU
DON'T HAVE THE SAME ACCESS
THAT'S AFFORDED TO OTHER FOLKS.
SO JUST GETTING TO CALIFORNIA,
MAKING SURE YOUR PHYSICIAN, YOU
HAVE A PHYSICIAN WHO CAN INFORM
YOU THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA, AND
CREATING A WAY IN WHICH THAT
INFORMATION GETS TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. AND WE
KNOW ARIZONA HAS A LOT OF THEM,
SO THAT THEY HAVE FULL ACCESS TO
THE CARE THAT'S POTENTIALLY
AVAILABLE TO THEM, EVEN HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHAT I
WOULD HATE TO SEE IS THAT ONLY
WEALTHY WHITE WOMEN FROM ARIZONA
HAVE A PHYSICIAN THAT'S
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA, HOW DO
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE SERVING
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
ARIZONA, HOW DO THOSE POTENTIAL
PATIENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION? JODY HICKS DID
SPEAK TO THIS A LITTLE BIT AT
THE PRESS CONFERENCE. SHE TALKED
ABOUT THE NETWORK THAT
SYMPHONY'S ALSO MENTIONING THAT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD HAS WITH THE
CLINICS, PARTICULARLY THE
CLINICS IN ARIZONA, MANY OF
WHICH ALREADY HAVE RECIPROCAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH DOCTORS IN CALIFORNIA. VÀ,
AND THAT I BELIEVE THIS WILL BE,
THE WORD OF MOUTH PIECE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR, I THINK WILL
FLOW THROUGH THOSE CLINIC
PROVIDERS AND THROUGH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I KNOW ABOUT THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD NETWORK, AND
I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU ALL ARE
LIFTING THIS UP AND HELPING TO
PROTECT THOSE WOMEN WHEREVER
THEY ARE. I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
SURE. ONE IS WITH, SENATOR
ARCHULETA'S COMMENT. SO BECAUSE
YOU MADE A MENTION, MADAM CHAIR,
TO SENATOR NILO THAT THIS IS A
VERY SPECIFIC PROCEDURE HERE,
HERE NOT TO, YOU KNOW, DO
ANYTHING ELSE BUT THAT WHAT IF
AND HE MENTIONED I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY, GET A CLARIFICATION.
WHAT IF DURING THAT PROCEDURE
SOMETHING HAPPENS, RIGHT, RIGHT,
KIDNEY FAILURES, LOSS OF BLOOD,
WHATEVER. SO FIRST QUESTION IS
CAN THEY PERFORM LIFE SAVING
BECAUSE IT'S OUTSIDE THAT
PROCEDURE. YEAH. SECOND, IF THE
PATIENT NEEDS TO BE TRANSPORTED
TO THE HOSPITAL, HOW DOES THE
HOSPITAL GO ABOUT ACCEPTING THAT
DOCTOR TO COME IN AND CONTINUE
THAT? IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THAT'S THE IMPORT OF THE BILL
BECAUSE THE BILL GIVING
LICENSURE ACCEPTABILITY TO THE
ARIZONA DOCTOR GIVES THEM THE
PERMISSIONS THEY NEED TO THEN
TAKE THAT PATIENT TO THE
HOSPITAL AND STAY WITH THEM AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT CARE.
ANYTHING THAT WOULD HAPPEN TO A
PATIENT IN THE PROCESS OF A
PROCEDURE WOULD, OF COURSE, BE
HANDLED BY THAT DOCTOR. I THINK
YOUR QUESTION IS IF SOMETHING
ELSE HAPPENED IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE PROCEDURE AND SUDDENLY WE'RE
IN AN EMERGENCY SITUATION, WE
NEED SOMETHING FAR MORE
INTENSIVE. COULD THAT DOCTOR
STAY? TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
DOCTOR IS COMFORTABLE PERFORMING
THOSE ADDITIONAL DUTIES? THE
ANSWER IS YES, BECAUSE THEY
WOULD THEY WOULD BE A DOCTOR
FULLY FLEDGED IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S JUST THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO SEE SOMEBODY WHO IS HERE FOR
HEART SURGERY USING THIS,
BECAUSE THAT HEART SURGEON WOULD
HAVE HAD TO HAVE PERFORMED AN
ABORTION IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
IN ARIZONA TO QUALIFY FOR THIS
RECIPE. LOCAL AGREEMENT TO
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA. SO SO,
YES. IF THE PERSON IF THE DOCTOR
CAME WITH THE PATIENT AND WAS
PERFORMING THIS FORM OF HEALTH
CARE TO THE WOMAN AND THE WOMAN
FOR SOME REASON STARTED TO HAVE
A PROBLEM, THAT DOCTOR WOULD BE
ABLE TO SEE IT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH AND WOULD HAVE IS A
FULLY FLEDGED DOCTOR BY OUR
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS FOR THAT
PERIOD OF TIME. SO BUT WOULD
ALSO HAVE THE SUPPORTS OF THESE
FACILITIES. AND WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT BACK ROOMS
SOMEWHERE. THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT. THAT'S WHAT WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE HAPPEN. WE THINK IF WE
DON'T DO THIS, THERE WILL BE
PEOPLE. EIGHT WEEKS SEEMS LIKE A
REALLY SHORT WINDOW, BUT I'VE
HAD THREE KIDS AND, EIGHT WEEKS
IN A PREGNANCY IS A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL PERIOD OF TIME AND
THE FIRST EIGHT WEEKS OF A
PREGNANCY. IT'S IRONIC THAT
THAT'S THE AMOUNT, BECAUSE
THAT'S A REALLY CRITICAL PERIOD
OF TIME, IN A PREGNANCY. SO WE
DON'T WANT TO CLOSE THAT WINDOW
FOR THOSE EIGHT WEEKS, BECAUSE
DOING SO AS I THINK SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS IS POINTING OUT
ELOQUENTLY FOR A LOT OF WOMEN,
WOULD, WOULD PREVENT THEM FROM
EVER BEING ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED. EIGHT WEEKS IS
SUBSTANTIAL. SO THAT'S THAT'S
WHY THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL,
SENATOR SKINNER SEAS, WANTS TO
SEE IT THROUGH ALL THE WAY
THROUGH, BECAUSE WE WANT TO
PROVIDE FOR THE WOMEN IN ARIZONA
, THE HEALTH CARE STANDARDS THAT
ARE CLOSER TO 2024 THAN 1864.
I'M GOING TO ASK ONE MORE
QUESTION. MALPRACTICE I MEAN, DO
THEY CARRY THEIR INSURANCE OVER?
HOW DOES THAT WORK? AND SECOND
PART TO THAT IS, OR TO THE FIRST
PART, ANOTHER QUESTION IS THE
HOSPITAL, HOW DOES THE HOSPITAL
KNOW THAT THIS DOCTOR IS
QUALIFIED, ETC? I MEAN, I'M
ASSUMING WHEN DOCTORS COME IN
THERE, THEY HAVE A LIST AND WE
KNOW WHO THEY ARE AND THE
HOSPITAL IS COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
IN ORDER TO BE A DOCTOR AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROCESS IS. YEAH,
IN ORDER TO BE A MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL DOING THIS TYPE OF
PROCEDURE IN ARIZONA, YOU'D
ALREADY HAVE TO HAVE THAT
INSURANCE. IT WOULD FOLLOW YOU
SINCE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THEIR
OWN PATIENT FROM ARIZONA. IT'S
NOT A CALIFORNIA PATIENT THAT'S
GOING TO FOLLOW THEM TO. THE
ONLY THING THAT MIGHT CHANGE
WOULD BE JURISDICTION, WHICH IS
THE WHOLE POINT. OKAY. GREAT.
THANK YOU. YEAH SURE. SENATOR
ARCHER, LET IN REFERENCE TO MY
COLLEAGUE QUESTION ABOUT
FINANCES, THE PATIENT IS NOT
GOING TO BE, BURDENED WITH ANY
FINANCIAL, HEADACHES AFTER THIS
IS OVER BECAUSE I'M ASSUMING
THERE WAS THERE WAS SOME
ARRANGEMENT FROM ARIZONA THAT IT
WOULD BE PAID. AND THIS WAY IT'S
OPEN TO EVERYBODY. I MEAN,
THAT'S THE WHOLE IDEA IS THAT
WHO'S WHO'S FINALLY PAYING FOR
THE PROCEDURE? ARIZONA. THIS
BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE A
FIDUCIARY COMPONENT. THIS IS
JUST A LICENSURE COMPONENT. BUT
AS I THINK SENATOR NILO AND
SENATOR NGUYEN HAVE POINTED OUT,
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY TAKEN
SEVERAL POSITIONS IN PREVIOUS
BILLS THAT DO PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE TO FOLKS THAT NEED TO
COME HERE AND NEED HELP. PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS ALSO THE CHAMPION
FOR THOSE RESOURCES. BUT SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS'S POINT IS, IS
THAT THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
WOULD BE ABLE TO AFFORD AN
AIRLINE TICKET AND TO PAY FOR
THEIR DOCTOR TO COME OUT HERE,
AND THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
WOULDN'T THIS BILL DOES NOT
ADDRESS THAT. BUT WHAT DOES
ADDRESS THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
SHE'S SAYING. THE CLINICAL
FRIENDS AND RECIPROCITY THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN THE CLINICS AND
PLANNED PARENTHOOD. SO THEY
WOULD BE WORKING THAT PIECE OUT.
SO TO HER POINT, HER POINT IS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW THAT
THIS IS POSSIBLE AND AVAILABLE
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE RECEIVING
THEIR SERVICES AND CARE IN THOSE
CLINICS, AND THAT THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO COME HERE
AS WELL. THIS BILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT, BUT IT CREATES THE
NECESSARY COMPONENT FOR
LICENSURE TO THEN ENABLE FOLKS
TO USE SOME OF THE OTHER
RESOURCES THAT MY CONCERN WAS
THAT THE PATIENT WOULDN'T BE
BURDENED WITH EXPENSES THAT THEY
WEREN'T PREPARED FOR. THEY MIGHT
BE, BUT THIS BILL WOULDN'T
CREATE THOSE EXPENSES ANY
DIFFERENT THAN, WOULD BE
NECESSARY FOR THEM SOMEWHERE
ELSE. THIS BILL DOESN'T ADDRESS
THE FINANCIAL COMPONENT. WHERE
THE QUALITY IS WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR. RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. YEAH.
THANK YOU. YEP. COLLEAGUES. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME,
MADAM CHAIR, I'M GOING TO PAUSE
SO WE CAN, ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE. ASHBY
HERE. ASHBY HERE. WHEN HERE.
WHEN HERE. ALVARADO. GIL.
ALVARADO HERE. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA. HERE. BECKER. DODD
DODD. HERE. EGGMAN. GLASER.
LASER. HERE MENGIBAR. HERE.
MENGIBAR. HERE. NILO. HERE NILO.
HERE. ROTH A ROTH HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE. WILK.
PRESENT PRESENT. WILK. PRESENT.
THANK YOU, AT THIS TIME, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? ACTUALLY, IS
THERE A MOTION? THERE'S A
MOTION. AND WOULD WE LIKE TO
CLOSE? SURE, JUST VERY BRIEFLY
SAY THAT I'M EXTREMELY PROUD
TODAY TO STAND IN FRONT OF YOU
AS A MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND HONORED TO EVEN TRY
TO FILL THE SHOES OF SENATOR
SKINNER AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THERE'S A THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. RIVAS THIS MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN. PLEASE CALL FOR
THE VOTE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
WHEN? NO. WHEN. NO. ALVORD. GILL
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA AYE.
BECKER. DODD. AYE. DODD AYE.
EGGMAN. GLASER. GLASER AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO.
NØ. NHIÀU NO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK NO. WILK. NO.
WILL KEEP THE ROLL CALL OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU
.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S CALL THE ROLL
ONE MORE TIME. SB 233. MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN CURRENT VOTES 8 TO
3. BECKER. AYE BECKER. AYE.
EGGMAN. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S
IT. SO THE BILL IS 9 TO 3.
THAT'S OUT. AND HEADED TO. WHERE
ARE WE GOING? SENATE FLOOR. ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL SEE THIS BILL
NEXT ON THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK
YOU EVERYONE. THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.